en gros
qu est-ce qu héros
doit tenir une bm oui oui
[Musique]
c'est pas humain stator 27,2 m réveil un
dimanche matin hier on a testé la bnc
laïque ce super cool ax ce n'est rien et
aujourd'hui on va aller se faire la i 4
on n'est plus dans de la berline non des
moindres ont pu dans l'idée du gros a su
rendre un peu moins de performances de
calcul pour tout ce qui va être
assistante route et compagnie mais par
contre on reçoit dans l'adn de bmw
grosse berline électrique sais plus
combien de chevaux va regarder ça tu te
laisse le temps de ce bâton qu'une âme
et roanne
ne pas commencer les vidéos
avec des années comme toi j'ai pas
besoin d'ennemis voilà cours mais les
chaussures et pourquoi t'as vu mes
chaussettes de noël on s'attend à voir
des belles choses c'est de l'acquis des
peuples c'est les plus profondes aux
classes et des chaussures mes 14 ans
ça me fera un garrot donc je vais
arrêter a lyon vers déjeuner première
chose à faire le matin on va déjeuner on
est dans un ancien cinéma pays où c'est
un cloître et ses
savoir faire le truc qui livre on a eu
hier soir on a mangé leur comme ça je
vous donne tous regardé la salle est
magnifique parce que j'aurai envie de
faire c'est comme dans la pub c'était de
please ni où elle arrivait dans les
années 80 et à
les contenir
ça serait magnifique non alors le petit
déj c'est par là ses écrits ses petits
déjeuners et les petits déjeuners c'est
le repas le plus important de la journée
c'est là qu'on va manger et qui on va
enfin monsieur nicolas
les parties
[Musique]
regardez où ils nous emmènent bmw c'est
le petit hôtel-restaurant barça et crée
ici c'est fontevraud c'est une abbaye du
siècle voilà et puis entre nous c'est le
départ via la moco regarde on a toutes
les voitures qui sont alignés on est
prêt à partir hier on s'est fait la x là
on va se faire un tour de vis 4004 n 5
bmw 100% électrique et surtout alors on
nous a dit tiens qu'est ce que vous
voulez prendre comme véhicule de demain
parce qu'on a regardé que vous avez
plein de couleurs différentes vous avez
celle là qui est sur un côté un petit
peu bordeaux sympa vous avez ce gris
avec un côté un peu bleus très pâle mais
nous on s'est dit non russell à la bas
côté bleu électrique elle est hyper
canon on va se la prendre on va passer
la journée ensemble on va tous regardé
je vais tout vous dire vous allez tout
savoir sur cette nouvelle et 4 m 5 elle
est belle on va aller dedans on va
l'essayer on va se balader on va se
promener vers tours vers blois on va
remonter vers paris cris tout va prendre
du plaisir parce que plaisir c'est beau
et ça c'est important de plaisir tel
accord avec moi tout ce que je lui que
pour son
confrère mute étonné à l'eonia
meba on est bas mon coco taille et un
dos d'âne tient la caméra tient la
caméra car les caméras en fait
tu as senti et la levée
on est super bas par rapport la x n'a
rien à voir ce message hyper chanson là
on était hyper le cul ça brûle en fait
on est en bleu remonte un peu plus la
gemmi à force je m'adapte très fort
c'est vrai que la x on est beaucoup plus
haut et c'est l'esprit et suivait donc
on à la hauteur et on domine un peu la
route là on est très bas on est vraiment
temps l'idée de la berline sport un peu
coupé sport de bmw mais sinon on se sent
vraiment un petit quart toilettes ça
marche comme on n'est pas là
ça chauffe ça pour femmes le bas du dos
sinon attention ça va sauter ils ont
déconné passage éclair
[Musique]
oui
544 chevaux on en électrique et comme on
a un électrique vous savez un couple de
dingue on appuie en 3,9 secondes on
passe de 0 à 100 c'est absolument
démentielle ça marche super bien alors
attention ici autonomie on nous annonce
590 kilomètres quand on part comme ça
nous on va marquer directement 350 alors
est-ce que je menais en mode sport ou
pas je ne sais pas on les a pas encore
fait complètement on a un gros réseau de
recharge en fait ce que nous propose ici
bmw vous avez la petite car bmw mais la
grande car bmw prévient vont changer sur
le réseau et unity vous avez en tout 80
points de recharge en france a fait en
tout plus de 400 banques sur le réseau
et en plus ces cartes vous permet
également d'accéder au réseau total
total levé vous avez énormément demande
en fait vous avez le choix des bornes
sur autoroute des bandes-son route le
mieux encore avec une voiture comme ça
c'est venir recharger chez vous de faire
installer une borne en triphasé pour le
recharger la nuit et repartir en toute
sécurité le matin le modèle qu'on
affiche lee 4ème 50 on est à 71 1650
euros on va trouver comment et sur l'aim
50 et bien le petit m qui est ici et on
a au niveau des finitions venir trouver
également les petites couleurs sans
votre ceinture ça c'est de l'intérieur
donc l'intérieur on va se le faire dans
quelques instants mais venez voir parce
que c'est un véhicule qui est
extrêmement races et les gens sont juste
magnifique on a des lignes qui sont
complètement d'un à la loue qui est
vraiment hyper agressive et pour y
reprendre la route avec ça c'est un vrai
bonheur d'un petit coffre à l'arrière
ben ouais c'est plus pratique pour les
ranger ses affaires alors nous on a
mieux les valises regardez moi ce petit
bazar qu'on a mis là on a même des
paniers-repas wec ans que chez bmw 12e
les millefeuilles ne croyait pas la plus
zen les mille feuilles et les
clémentines ils pensent à nous et ça
c'est gentil merci bien w alors après
une fois de plus j'ai pas être un
spécialiste automobile monstre
spécialistes aig dont je vous parle tout
l'électronique embarquée on va venir
faire un petit tour de l'intérieur c'est
quand même le point qui nous intéresse
alors moi ce que j'aime déjà beaucoup
c'est la finition de la série m vous
retrouver sur les ceintures les
finitions sont magnifiques sur les
sièges de la même manière on ne le
retrouver ici là ce côté là voyez les
petites couleurs de la série n 16 bat
quai ils sont vraiment super super super
beau pour en prêt je vous passe un vous
avez voilà petit rangement vous avez ce
qu'il faut ce qui est intéressant sur la
partie centrale convenir retrouver ici
bré votre petite molette pour venir
naviguer on a accès rapidement menu
média ohm ap / tout marrant ça on
pourrait se dire tiens tout est traduit
en français pour elle ne mettrait pas
maisons pour ça rien on met au banc
entrées c'est vraiment du point de
détail on a du rangement de tous les
côtés on a une prise usb 3 ça c'est
intéressant c'est pas de l'usbc alors
que sur l'aï dit on à de l'usb c'est
l'agent n'est pas donc là je suis un peu
frustré j'aimerais avoir le sbc j'en ai
pas donc ça dommage alors j'ai toujours
mon petit 12 volts là ça c'est plutôt
cool mais voyez c'est marrant alors là
si la g us baissé mais là j'en ai pas
quoi par mètre en l'arrachant c'est rien
c'est c'est des choix alors ce qui est
vraiment intéressant ici alors je vous
passe le côté volant qui est super bon
on a les finitions de la série m
également ici mais ce qui est
intéressant c'est ses deux écrans j'ai
un seul grand tableau devant centre
espace de grandes tables est qu en fait
j'ai deux écrans suisses à l'écran de
12,3 pouces voir toutes mes informations
essentielles te dire ma vitesse non
epower ou est-ce que j'en suis au niveau
de ma consommation je vois ma
récupération d'énergie également jeu
phare l'autonomie restante la sorte il
reste 324 km je vois la vitesse à
laquelle je dois rouler je vois où sont
assis les passagers s'il ya une ceinture
aussi a pas de ceinture je vois
l'autonomie restante bref si j'ai toutes
les informations sur mon véhicule
ensuite icij à l'écran 14 19 pouces est
exactement la même chose ils sont là ici
et là j'ai retrouvé toutes les
informations essentielles à la conduite
en rien ce qui est vachement intéressant
et café ici bmw c'est qu'en permanence
vous avez les informations concernant la
climatisation je vois ma température
pour mais chaque auteur jaser
synchronisée pour qu'on soit du même
côté et j'ai mon petit menu
climatisation sièges chauffants la
ventilation je choisis tout synchronie
synchronise pas bref c'est vachement
bien et ça on l'a tout le temps que ça
c'est plutôt cool je reviens ici et sur
la carte alors ma petite map l'aller
très pratique on a tous notre gps on va
aller notre menu home où je vais venir
pouvoir naviguer par exemple ici là j'ai
vraiment dans 53 dans un android en fait
ça je vous le dis à lille on a la vidéo
de la xe où je vais avoir toutes mes
informations essentielles je vois que
j'ai un androïde auto je peux avoir
apple car plaît ça c'est vachement bien
et une fois que j'aurai connecter entre
parenthèses on apple car plaît eh bien
j'ai retrouvé en bas toutes mes icônes
d'apple car plaimont spotify mais
message pour passer des appels
téléphoniques et si et ça ça c'est
plutôt bien je vais pouvoir retrouver
bien évidemment mon confort de
climatisation mon assistance belle et
mon éclairage intérieur ou spotify
également directement intégré la radio
la météo bref j'ai vachement
applications et j'aime beaucoup ce
système là parce que j'ai mis un père
très très facilement j'appuie je
comprends tout de suite où j'en suis un
accès aux réglages voyez avec le menu le
sous menu c'est vachement bien fait
c'est très bien construit très malin de
la part de bmw donc c'est vachement bien
donc là j'ai toutes les applis là je les
applique sont dédiés uniquement aux
véhicules mais différents réglages de
conduite du pouvoir choisir propulsion
châssis bref que ça vachement bien c'est
vraiment vraiment bien pensé et en terme
d'expérience logiciel je trouve que là
dessus bmw ont sorti une solution qui
est vachement intéressante c'est la
première fois qu'ils nous sont ceux
espèces de grands tableaux de bord sans
trace au grand écran un peu tourné vers
le conducteur légèrement incurvé mes
patrons peut vraiment profité à côté
vous et votre petite molette pour venir
naviguer les tactiles ont pu appuyer
dessus et en plus d'un tout qui est
vachement bien c'est la conduite est
haute et bien ce qui fait que l'ajax à
mon gps tout de suite je vois à quelle
vitesse je dois rouler je vois la
vitesse à laquelle je roule je vois n'a
direct shôjo de tourner à droite à
gauche or après j'ai toutes les
informations qu'on retrouve aujourd'hui
dans une automobile c'est à dire le lane
assist qui me permet de voir si je suis
sur mes lignes ou pas qui va m'aider
notamment sur l'autoroute enceintes ou
qui est vachement est à la santé j'avais
beaucoup aimé nous ont expliqué lors de
la course de presque en fait avec la x
vous avez 20 % de puissance de calcul en
plus ce rapport à la et 4 donc il sait
ce qu'il faut retenir c'est grand écran
l'expérience a les superbes 12 à 23
pouces
14,9 pouces android autocar plaît cette
typologie à d'icônes qui est vraiment
super bien la conduite est haute les
nouvelles générations un chez bmw la
version logicielle fois ci c'est la
huitième génération logiciel bref ça
marche du feu de dieu et ce qui est
génial je trouve vraiment un talent à
son c'est de voir toutes ces nouvelles
techno qui arrive directement ici dans
cette bmw y est super d évolution et en
termes de confort de conduite en terme
d'expérience logiciels en termes de
connectivité ils ont fait un boulot qui
est vraiment bien et qui a rien à envier
à un tesla qui est fier une des
références aujourd'hui en terme
d'automobile connectés on n'aura pas le
côté afin qu'ils d'une tesla où elle va
pas danser on n'aura pas un écran de
voir caler netflix et disney plus mais
pour autant ce qu'on trouve ici c'est
des menus qui sont très intuitifs qui
marche bien en plus on a un assistant
personnel peut venir appuyer ici dû
poser des questions ferme toutes les
vitres
il ya des moments où elle a un peu de
mal et des moments ça marche vachement
bien je sais pas pourquoi bref c'est en
tout cas vous l'avez là il ya un truc
qui est intéressante parce que vous avez
branché un apple car plaît eh bien vous
une fonction pour siri donc vous appuyer
là vous avez siri vous allez retrouver
sur votre écran central votre navigation
avec siri au milieu donc c'est vachement
intéressant c'est plein de petites
fonctionnalités qui sont très cool et
qui font que de ceux de bmw i iv
également de la xe que je vais présenter
quelques jours de très beaux véhicules
connectés et l'expérience a du stock bon
à l'arrière ici on n'a pas beaucoup de
place à faux pas est très très grand
pour autant la très jolie finition sur
les ceintures toujours pareil les
finitions de la série m c'est vachement
bien avoir trouvé 2 ports usb c'est en
bas on a une climatisation intégré qu'on
peut venir à lui mais en première église
température mais là par contre vous
allez mettre des enfants des enfants qui
n'est pas de très courtes sans quoi en
terme de confort c'est pas ouf vous
n'allez pas manger les kilomètres parce
que ça reste quand même très étroit et à
notre truc est vachement bien et on va
se gardant quelques instants c'est que
vous avez dû sont quatre décès vraiment
cool signé harman kardon
ils ont mis le paquet aussi au niveau de
l'audio alors vous avez vu on a les
enceintes avec harman kardon là je vous
ai ni du son on va monter le son vous
allez vous rendre ça on l'avait vu
également avec la x vous avez un son de
ma boule clarté au niveau des aigus et
graves qui rendra des places en a même
des petits n'y a qu'un seul traitement
plus poussé fort et ça sature pas enfin
10,5 et d'agde c'est que le son reste de
tring l'air très d'un guidage et ça
envoie du bois
j'sais pas si vous avez une clarté du
son à fort niveau
normalement plus vous allez monter si
vous voulez le niveau des haut parleurs
leçon fort et un moment vous avez un
risque de saturation au niveau de la
vibration de la membrane et là ça sature
pas c'est vraiment extrêmement
impressionnant hallyday s'est pas
d'écouter le son à grands pourront pas
se rendre fou mais voyez l'assurance -
et de l'électro ça marche vraiment bien
pour l'équipe et avec du méthane c'était
moi ça alors après ça dépend vraiment de
la source il faudrait en vous une bonne
qualité avec du supect qui soit assez
dingue mais là là
[Musique]
moi je veux qu'on parle un petit peu
rectification ou je veux qu'on parle de
grinta touche à tout qui est super
intéressant quand on repense à bmw
historiquement on pense forcément moteur
thermique et c'est normal et je trouve
que cette voiture là bien qu'on soit sûr
de l'électrique on a un aspect ce qu'on
appelle un peu un look and feel qui va
être un peu thermique pour autant s'en
est pas une du tout on garde l'esprit
bmw ont gain l'esprit rien si on garde
l'esprit je dire assez agressive de ce
genre de voiture on sent que c'est la
voiture qui demandent de la performance
on sent quand on appuie sa tartine on le
voit franchement déjà rien que le petit
logo en salle marche mais pour autant
chez bmw sont pas super boulot au niveau
de l'électrification bien évidemment il
ya un côté très green alors j'ai des
chiffres à vous donner j'ai un iphone
avec une coque monsieur heureux qu'on
n'est pas là pour se marrer bien
évidemment alors regarder en face ce
qu'ils ont fait ils utilisent des
matériaux recyclés extraits sur la x ou
sur l'a64 là derrière il ya 30 % de
matériaux recyclés j'utilise trois fois
moins de co balkans le cobalt sa demande
d'aller puiser des terres rares qui vont
forcément être un peu plus compliqué à
extraire et notamment en chine non bon
là il y en a trente fois moins donc ça
c'est bien il ya un recyclage des
batteries qui se fait à plus de 90% et
il maîtrise pas ce que les batteries
ceux qui les font à l'horizon des sous
traitants pour les cellules mais ce qui
est super intéressant c'est que si vous
avez une cellule qui ne fonctionne pas
chez nous vous avez un problème eh bien
ils ont la capacité d'intervenir ils
vont prendre la cellule qui marchent pas
ils vont l'enlever ils vont mettre une
qui marche ça permettra d'emmener votre
batterie beaucoup plus loin ça rajoute
en durabilité il ya une vraie maîtrise
ici de a à z qui fait par bmw ce qui
permet d'avoir une voiture propre qui
ira plus loin c'est plus écologique et
c'est mieux pour l'environnement et ça
c'est bien alors après le temps qu'il
faut savoir c'est que vous avez quatre
roues motrices ça veut dire que vous
avez un moteur à l'avant vous avez
également un moteur à l'arrière alors je
vous invite à les voir des chaînes qui
vont être spécialisé dans l'automobile
pour vous parler de la motorisation
comme ça vous saurez tout en termes de
performances entre deux puissances en
termes de batterie moi ce que j'ai aimé
ici effectivement c'est qu'on sent qu'on
des voitures qui tient la route ça tient
le pavé ça bouge pas ça dérape alors la
route un peu mou est donc toujours
tendance à faire un petit peu gaffe mais
pour autant on a un truc est vachement
bien et pour aller se balader sur les
chemins de campagne aura pas de souci
moi je suis toujours interloquée de voir
des voitures aussi compétitive aussi
bien fini et des voitures qui est
maintenant une autonomie vraiment
remarquable c'est toujours étonnant le
progrès que l'on a fait on s'aperçoit
qu'on se dirige rapidement vers ce type
de véhicule pour y aller sur
l'électrique ah oui oui moi j'attends
l'électrique sur des voitures qui ne
sont pas de cette gamme là et tout ça
mais immanquablement on bien les
voitures c'est pas franchement ma tasse
de thé mais je suis admiratif devant ses
conceptions
ya un truc qui est vachement bien enfin
que c'est une assistance à la conduite
et sur autoroute ça marche vraiment mais
alors il ya une différence par rapport à
x que nous est montrée assez compact
leaks elle va permettre de capter
beaucoup plus loin ce qui se passe de
mieux anticiper parce qu'on a plus de
performances il ya un calcul qui serait
qui est beaucoup plus rapide est ici
parce que j'aime beaucoup c'est
qu'effectivement vous avez une vraie
dallas conduit donc là y'a quoi y'a line
ainsi donc il laisse dans ma ville je
dois toujours garder une main sur le
volant parce que j'ai pas le droit
d'avoir une conduite totalement tout
neuf cantons j'ai forcément la main sur
le volant et si j'ai lâché au bout d'un
moment et bien je crois que ça se met en
couleur orange après sa main en rouge ça
s'arrête on se fait sans être autoroute
d'un coup ça c'est quand même un peu
ballot donc là je me suis calé à 130g
lane assist l'est dans ma voix je laisse
une main sur le volant mais pour autant
je suis plus cool plus relâché je dois
rester vigilant ce qui se passe mais lui
va tourner il va me bifurquer la voiture
ils la gardent à bonne vitesse enfin
tout ça vachement bien c'est extrêmement
pratique et sur les trajets un peu long
comme ça eh bien ça demande d'avoir un
peu moins d'intention faut toujours être
vigilant bien évidemment mais c'est
quand même pas la même chose donc là
j'ai pas les pieds sur les pédales juste
une main posée sur le volant et en avant
guingamp ça peut paraître tout bête
parce que ça existe à une assistée pas
tout nouveau mais pour autant ce qui est
vachement bien fait que c'est très bien
maîtrisé une fois de plus de la part bm
et quand on est sur une voiture haut de
gamme comme ça les voitures premium et
bien il ya il ya un confort de trajet il
ya un confort de conduite il ya beaucoup
moins de fatigue à l'arrivée c'est tout
plein de petits détails qui font que
c'est super intéressant le rend presque
on attend c'est une voiture qui sera
totalement autonome on pourra lâcher le
volant et on pourra se regarder un film
une série on n'y est pas encore mais la
voyez ce lâche ça conduit alors je vais
poser nos mains parce qu'on veut faire
la tronche et pour autant c'est cool
pour la charger c'est facile on ouvre sa
assez bien on prend cette petite chose
ben oui forcément on vient se
positionner dans sa voiture et une fois
que vous l'avez fait vous prenez votre
carte bmw de charger souvenez vous la
posez la vérification et la sava se
recharge est donc là on est à combien
tout de suite là on est à 51 % et on
repartira quand on sera à 80 % je sais
pas quoi on a petit 2000 heures et après
on est reparti sur la route sans aucun
problème et ça c'est cool voilà vous
savez tout vous a tout raconté sur cette
nouvelle bmw
ils 4ème 5 super intéressant de pouvoir
découvrir que ce soit la xc givet qui
l'a tout de suite et un super modèle
personnellement le coup de coeur pour
moi il est sur la x mais j'aime aussi
beaucoup la hica très racée dans ce que
sait faire bmw très très très bonne
voiture a vous de me dire ce que vous en
pensez en bons commentaires comment
est-ce que vous la trouvez entre soi
bien évidemment laïque à celle sujet de
la vidéo si vous n'avez pas vu la vidéo
sur la x et bien les jeter un coup
d'oeil à les gagner évidemment sur ma
chaîne là on est entre amis de
jean-baptiste yo yo yo enfin le rap
contenders je m'appelle aurélien et je
suis granet j'avais me venger des gras
ni et ma grand mère c'est une grave
voilà il ya le niveau tu fais du rap
maintenant là on à 96 dans cette affaire
un raid montrent aussi parce qu'en fait
tu t'apprêtes à 80% sa décidément la
vitesse de charges que la bomba c'est ok
allez
allez salut raccroche
[Musique]